pas de coca au pour cette présidentielle
au niger comme l'affirment l'expression
il y aura bien un second tour après 24
heures d'attentes la ceni confirme
mohamed bazoum avec 33 33% des voix
affrontera au second tour le président
mahamane ousmane qui n'a obtenu que 17 %
lors de ce premier tour les suffrages
exprimés valable ces mères à 4 millions
778 573 mes suffrages exprimés voilà ce
que je viens de vous donner pour un taux
de participation de 69,67 procès mais
l'écart est insuffisant pour proclamer
un vainqueur
l'heure est désormais à la recherche
d'alliances pour pouvoir succéder à
mamadou issoufou avant le second tour
prévu pour le 20 février prochain
parmi les nombreux partis politiques et
la trentaine de candidats les anciens
premiers ministres signe oumarou arrivé
troisième et albadé abouba quatrième du
même bord politique pourrait en faire
partie
seul ibrahim yacouba ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères arrivé 5e reste dans
l'opposition mahamadou issoufou 68 ans
après deux mandats constitutionnels
avaient décidé de ne pas se représenter
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du pays qu'un président élu succédera un
autre président élu une fierté pour le
président sortant
c'est un jour spécial pour moi mais
surtout pour le niger qui connaîtra pour
la première fois de son histoire une
alternance démocratique à la fin du
processus électoral il y aura un
vainqueur et quels qu'ils soient
la victoire appartiendra au peuple
nigérien une belle avancée pour
l'histoire démocratique du niger dans ce
pays en proie à des attaques jadis
récurrentes
la population n'a absolument pas été
découragé un taux de participation de
plus de 60 9% a été relevé et 5,2
millions de votants selon la céni
les résultats doivent encore être
validés par la cour constitutionnelle
hier encore une attaque par des hommes
armés avaient dû à tombo banques
un village de la région de tillabéri
dans l'ouest du niger tuant au moins 70
personnes
le rendez vous est donc pris pour le 21
février prochain avec un espoir pour le
pays
écrire une nouvelle page de son histoire